Amazon has rolled out this pay toplay
advertising scheme that is actually
showing consumers less relevant results
and steering them to more expensive
products has FTC chairwoman Lena KH ever
been to a grocery store what she
described there isn't new and it's not
unique to Amazon have you ever seen
these before big displays at the end of
aisles that are designed to grab your
attention yeah they're advertising
schemes meant to steer consumers to
certain products companies have been
doing this for forever just because
Amazon is doing it online doesn't make
it illegal and it's certainly not
evidence of a monopoly agency claims
that Amazon Prime subscription fee makes
consumers feel compelled to keep using
Amazon yeah that's how subscriptions
work if you subscribe to Netflix Netflix
knows that it'll continue getting your
business does that make Netflix a
monopoly of course not and neither is
Amazon